everyone welcome to the live stream you
are rocking with me i am dionne robowen
markets reporter for the wall street
journal i want to welcome you into this
special thursday edition it's a weekend
edition or an end of the week addition
to the live stream uh good friday is
tomorrow so both the stock and bond
markets are closed so we are doing this
special uh wrap up weekly edition of the
live stream today i want to appreciate
everyone who's tuning in and thank in
advance all the people who will tune in
even though they won't see this
and if you're watching this on replay on
the channel thank you for watching and i
hope you'll be with us when we do it
again on monday like i said this is a
live stream we're trying this out we're
going to talk through everything that's
going on in markets everything that's
moving the markets basically everything
that's uh that's important if you read
the wall street journal all the big news
happening that's moving money around so
thanks to everybody for tuning in um i
am dion rabon as i said and we are going
to get into everything we got earnings
this week we've had some more big moves
in the stock market big moves in the
bond market and we're going to be
talking through all of that
obviously like i said earnings season we
got day two of the banks today which was
uh not so great
a lot of interesting news to go through
uh it's been a rough week for stock
market really um and today if you've
been invested in the nasdaq or you know
the s p 500 it's been another rough day
for you and what is turning out to be a
pretty rough week i'm going to tell you
why we're seeing some of those moves
kind of tracing back some of that stuff
from last week also bond yields we are
back up over 2.75
on the 10-year note i'm going to talk a
little bit about why that's happening
what's going on and some of the kind of
chain reaction or the the effects the
ripple effects of that 10-year move also
talking through what data we got this
week cpi was the big one the consumer
price index telling us what inflation is
looking like for us consumers but also
the ppi producer price index dropped
earlier this week that was a big number
we'll talk through that as well as
today's retail sales report and the
university of michigan consumer
sentiment index
that's what all we'll be going through
and i'm going to tell you what to look
out for next week
it is a big week for the housing market
we got some big news on the housing
market today next week we're going to
see a number of different
indicators national weekly daily all
kinds of things so i'm going to tell you
what to be looking out for then so again
thanks to everyone for tuning in to the
live stream
checking in on the stock market right
now like i said it's a rough day unless
you're in the dow you're breaking even
if you've got that dow
dow jones industrials etf
that's about 0.4 percent on wsj.com the
s p 500 down about 0.75
and the nasdaq down about 1.6 percent
recovering a little bit of that loss
from earlier today but still uh in tough
territory or you know still looking like
things are a little bit rough there
we've got the u.s 10-year yield up about
2.8 percent right now um things really
you know moving in sort of a negative
direction if you are a bond holder
yields going up which means price is
going down which means if you're holding
a 10-year you're losing money um oil uh
up again today we're up about one
percent on wti brent crew to little ope
up a little over one percent as well and
uh gold down about half a percent
checking out the crypto market bitcoin
down three percent today ethereum down
2.6 percent so you know a tough day in
the market we're seeing kind of a
sell-off across the board in all asset
classes uh just checking in real quick
when i hit you with a little bit of the
news that we've got today the big story
obviously elon musk talking about buying
twitter
the market though is saying we don't
believe you you need more people uh elon
musk putting out there a bit of 54 20
per share for twitter
money that he doesn't necessarily have
he could borrow from his stake in in
tesla or his stake in spacex
we're seeing the shares of tesla down
today maybe on the expectation that musk
will sell more shares but
twitter stock uh declining today and
again musk put up that target of 54.20 a
share the stock price for twitter not
anywhere near that and in fact has gone
negative today so you know you got a
little bit of a pop when the news
initially came out but the mark is
saying not elon we don't believe you you
don't have the money
uh we'll see how that goes maybe he'll
get more serious maybe he won't
um also on wsj.com this morning jason
furman former advisor with the obama
administration out with an op-ed about
inflation and uh one of the things that
i think really doesn't get enough
attention a lot of people talk about
wages you know spiking up and that
spiking inflation but the cpi print
showed us we got 8.5 percent inflation
but consumer or sorry nominal wages
wages not adjusted for inflation only
rising 5.6
which means that actual wages
inflation-adjusted wages down 2.7
for workers so again workers actually
losing pricing power and losing more
pricing power even though those wages
are rising and 2.7 percent if you
remember watching from a video we did a
couple weeks ago uh 2.4 percent was what
workers lost last year so we're seeing
that wage loss accelerating that's not
good uh that shows that people's buying
power is further being eroded by
inflation also the european central bank
had its meeting today came out basically
doubled down on what they've been saying
for a while we are going to stop net
asset purchases in the third quarter but
the market not really feeling that the
euro hitting a two-year low versus the
dollar we don't talk about currencies
it's one of my first loves fx but very
important to watch is that euro level
sinks that euro dollar level one of the
the biggest most watched uh currencies
in the market so hitting a two year low
versus the dollar definitely important
something to keep your eye on for the
future again we are doing this live
stream i am dionne robowen uh you are on
my youtube channel thank you for tuning
in we're talking everything markets
we're gonna go through what all happened
this week and i'm gonna talk about what
you guys should look forward to next
week if you're an investor if you're
watching markets if you're concerned
about the economy overall so let's get
into it let's talk a little bit about
earnings season which kicked off this
week with jp morgan chase the world's or
not the worlds anymore the us's largest
bank uh profit declined by 42
uh now that sounds rough but they still
had a profit of 8.28 billion dollars
this quarter
i'm sorry last quarter in the first
quarter 8.28 billion dollars of profit
most of that miss on their on their
profits and on earnings was from loan
loss provisions basically what that
means is they expect to or are just
preparing to potentially lose money from
loans that they've made that are not
paid back they're putting money to the
side a lot of this was money that they
had put away in the first quarter of
2020 then in 2021 as it was clear or it
was clear to ceos and executives that
you know what the pandemic isn't going
to cause this long lasting recession
they wrote those loan losses off the
books and actually had negative loan
loss provisions now we're comparing
first quarter 2022 to first quarter 2021
and those losses look significant
because they're not making anywhere near
as much profit as they did because
they're just not putting money away it's
it's kind of like if you if you made a
thousand dollars last month and the year
before you made a thousand dollars but
you put you know
now you're putting away 500 well now
you've only got 500 left and you only
made 500 after you put that money away
last year you didn't put any money away
so you had a thousand dollars that's
basically what's happening here jp
morgan a lot of other banks we're gonna
get into that as well but i want to talk
a little bit about what that jpmorgan
earnings report told us about the
economy uh ceo damie dimon
warning that chase is building up its
credit reserves because of quote higher
probabilities of downside risk however
the loan losses or the loan loss
provisions they took
not very high according to historical
averages we'll get into that consumer
spending on credit cards at jpmorgan
chase rose 29
a 64 increase in spending on travel and
entertainment that speaks well for
services bouncing back up again we've
gotta even out the market people are
spending a lot on goods and that's kind
of gumming up the works that's a lot of
the shipping supply delays that we've
seen things like that when they spend
more on services that balances things
out we get a more balanced economy and
we can kind of bring down those delays
in the shipping industry and sort of
start to even out the economy hopefully
then inflation comes back down companies
maybe stop raising prices at the same
rate and things like that so that that
number is a good sign for the economy
again 29 increase in credit card
spending um 64 increase on travel and
entertainment also credit card increase
or credit card loans excuse me the fed
put out this report back in uh our at
the a couple weeks ago about what
happened in february we saw credit card
loans increasing 15
this is the trend i told you guys to
watch out for on the live stream a
couple weeks ago the fed's g19 report
that showed consumer credit surged 41.8
billion dollars in february and
essentially 42 billion dollars a 20.7
percent increase in consumer credit so
again watch out consumers are obviously
taking out a bunch more credit credit is
about to start getting much more
expensive if the fed raises rates as
they say they're going to do so
will we see that really break down are
consumers kind of seeing as prices rise
oh let me go make these purchases now
and then they're going to pull back or
will this continue that's definitely
something to watch out for
another very interesting part of this
jpmorgan earnings report auto loan
origination is dropping 25
we saw uh in the cpi report that auto
inflation actually declined 3.8 percent
that was one of the big things that
brought down the cpi and kept it from
being even higher than it was on a
month-over-month level so definitely
something to watch out for there we saw
a 41 jump in used car prices a 12 jump
in new car prices so prices rising
consumers not buying they're they're
declining and making less purchases 25
drop in auto origination at jpmorgan
chase we saw this uh through a number of
the different banks over the last couple
days
so definitely something to watch out for
what does this say about the economy
moving forward
deposits this is a good sign deposits
increased by 15 at jpmorgan chase again
the largest bank in the u.s showing a 15
increase in deposits shows that
consumers are still cash rich they're
still putting money away
for a rainy day
that's a good sign for the economy it
means that if things do go wrong there's
a cushion and a buffer built up to keep
folks from you know having to rely on
government services or not being
employed or not spending if something
goes wrong folks can still keep spinning
because they've got that money put away
these are good signs consumers have more
money seems like they're just spending
it a little bit more cautiously so
that's that's not a bad thing that's not
a bad thing uh we'll see i'm going to
tell you about what happened with retail
sales a little bit later um again
i want to just thank everyone who tuned
in on the live stream seeing that more
folks are trickling in appreciate you
i'm dion rabowen this is the wall street
journal i'm a reporter for the wall
street journal this is my youtube
channel thank you for tuning in to live
stream we're talking all things economy
um other banks want to talk about retail
or sorry not want to talk about earnings
uh goldman sachs again we saw this is a
theme we're seeing profits down 42 in
the first quarter for goldman sachs
wells fargo profits down 21
citigroup profits down 46
morgan stanley profits down 11
now that sounds catastrophic but
actually morgan stanley and city beat
expectations
so again a lot of this is coming off of
loan losses these companies are putting
more money away in case people don't pay
their loans
and
that's not necessarily a bad thing we're
just getting back up to kind of
historical levels in the first quarter
banks took a lot of money for loan loss
provisions off now they're putting it
back on
the loan loss provisions were only about
3.2 billion dollars 3.2 billion the
historical average going back to 2009 is
about 10 billion dollars over the last
five years it's about six billion
dollars so not even rising to that level
a lot of folks have said up watch out
this could be a sign of recession banks
are preparing for recession that's not
what the numbers tell us so trust the
numbers right now banks getting a little
bit more worried than they have been but
doesn't seem like they're actually
worried about big loan losses
and we saw the market really respond
with selling off chase but the banking
sector overall has held up relatively
well i remember we were expecting 36
uh decrease in profit growth uh for
banks and for the financial sector
according to factset for this first
quarter banks really just coming in
meeting that not as much profit still
lots of profit banks still making lots
of money so don't need to cry for them
just yet again looking at the market
broadly
we are down like i said today we're down
for the week it's looking like one thing
i thought was interesting was on tuesday
it looked like we were going to get a
rebound kind of that typical by the dip
bounce that we've seen after monday's
losses we did not get that and instead
ended the day lower and actually the s p
500 finished below 4 400 for the first
time since mid-march the nasdaq finished
below 14 000. those were two very
important kind of psychological levels
for the market it looks like we're going
to be finishing lower than that today
which means we'll finish lower than that
for the week something to watch out for
does this bearish momentum continue does
the market continue to keep going down
even though we've gotten some decent
news about the economy how are stock
market investors taking that news
again want to thank you guys for being a
part of the live stream this is what
we're talking about markets economy all
the things that go together to really
show how money is moving and how money
is going to move looking forward
you know my favorite topic bonds the
10-year yield at 2.8 percent we are
again moving towards that 3 level which
is going to be important for a lot of
folks because at 3
it becomes really attractive to move
some of that money into the 10-year note
into the 10-year yield
and to move some of that money maybe out
of the stock market which has been
volatile which has been showing losses
like it is today so
2.8 percent that's a pretty attractive
number uh if you're an investor and
you're you're taking on less risk than
you are potentially with the stock
market something to look out for the cpi
report that we got a lot of folks i was
reading a lot of commentary um from
folks like td securities um barclays a
lot of these people were saying you know
what i think we may have peaked uh we
may have peaked on the cpi at 8.5
percent which was the report that we got
on tuesday and now we're coming down
if that's the case it's very interesting
to see the 10-year yield continuing to
rise higher suggesting that more
inflation is priced in for a longer term
period for the market so definitely
something to look out for
another thing that was interesting about
where bond yields are just today we got
the report from freddie mac which is the
government tied organization over
overseeing mortgages that mortgage rates
hit five percent uh now that's a big
number it's a big psychological number
and we're going to be talking about that
i got a video coming out later today
hopefully uh that's gonna tell you all
about what that five percent number
means why it's the number that
economists watch and why it's number
that is going to price a lot more people
out of the housing market if rates stay
at that level so
please be sure to come back and check
out my page for that video that's going
to be dropping later on today
the other thing to note is that five
percent level according to
the mortgage bankers association hasn't
been hit since 2018
according to freddie mac which reported
it today that's the highest mortgage
rates have been since 2011. so more than
10 years since mortgage rates have been
as high as they are right now but in
2018 when we were around these levels
the fed was ending its hiking cycle
right the fed was coming to the end of
raising u.s interest rates and rates
were actually about to go down in the
next couple months this was in october
2018. right now
the fed is doing the opposite the fed is
about to just begin its rate hiking
cycle they've only raised once that was
in march so rates are going to actually
increase higher that's going to mean
higher rates for auto loans it's going
to mean higher rates on credit cards
things like that and we're going in a
bit of the opposite direction from where
we were in in 2018 when rates were last
this high so definitely something to
watch out for if you're watching the
mortgage market uh this might not be a
ceiling this could be something like a
floor but again
definitely something to watch out for
when you're watching that 10-year yield
because that goes directly to mortgage
rates they're tied pretty tightly um
also mba the mortgage bankers
association had an interesting report
out yesterday talking about this five
percent number but also pointing out
that overall mortgage originations are
expected to decline by 35.5 percent for
2021. again a 35 decline in mortgage
originations that's just people taking
out new mortgages whether that be for a
you know a refinance or to buy a new
house now a big portion of that is
refinancing and that number has fallen
like a stone over the past few months
refinancing going from about 70 of all
mortgage originations to
down to 50 to 40 to now it's at 37.1
of all mortgage applications that is a
significant number
we also got this week a number of fed
speakers influential fed speakers
including miss leal brainerd who is a
fed governor expected to be confirmed as
the vice chair
very soon we don't know when that's
going to happen but it's expected to
happen soon
she again kind of coming out and saying
hey you know what that 50 point increase
that the market is already priced in
we're probably going to do that we also
had james bullard who was a voter on
this year's rate committee saying yeah i
think 50 basis points is understood and
that seems like a reasonable thing for
us to do um another uh thomas barkin who
is a non-voter but also kind of coming
in and charles evans from the fed bank
of chicago saying yeah you know what i
think this is likely what we're going to
do so market is already priced in 50
basis points
and that looks like it is
locked in for may we'll see what the
communication starts look like for june
and you know what we've seen on from cpi
really has not suggested the fed could
back off but maybe we've peaked maybe
we've hit the the height of where
inflation is going to rise
and we'll see about that
like i said we got that 8.5 number on
cpi highest since december 1981.
um
we saw credit suites barclays bank of
america and of course td securities as i
mentioned all saying yeah i think we've
peaked so some big names coming out
there and saying that we've hit the
highest that inflation is going to go we
should start to come down
none of them however expect to see
inflation getting back toward the fed's
two percent goal which is their which is
what they strive for so we could see the
fed having to tighten rates having to
raise rates and really kind of tighten
up the economy for quite some time
another sign that that could be
happening is ppi producer price index
which is the cost that businesses are
paying that hit a record high 11.2
percent year over year and as we've seen
in an inflationary environment
businesses pass those costs on to
consumers i talked to my man lou breen
from drw trading he's the head us rage
strategist there he told me that it's
really ppi and cpi are being motivated
by two very different things ppi seems
to be dealing a lot more with this war
in ukraine and the russian ukraine
conflict whereas cpi seems to be getting
dragged down a lot by the fact that
we're not getting as much of that
stimulus consumers aren't getting that
big boost to their bank accounts that
they were a year ago and now without
that you could see spending start to
tail off and inflation for consumers
start to tail off but for businesses
prices continue to rise so
we already know that businesses raise
prices that boosts inflation but when
they don't have the pricing power when
consumers can't afford it they tend to
back off that so we will see what
happens there
as we come through
moving forward at the rest of the year
retail sales also that came out just
this morning we saw a point five percent
increase february's number also revised
higher from zero point three percent to
zero point eight percent that point five
percent number is respectable it's
decent it means consumers are still
spending more in retail sales but it's
about half of the increase month over
month as we saw in the cpi so inflation
is running at about 1.2 percent a month
retail sales running at 0.5 a month
that's that's not a recipe for success
so keep your eye on that one positive
note that we did see was the university
of michigan's consumer sentiment index
increased to 65.7 we were still at
around the lowest levels in 10 years but
that's up from reading of 59.4 in march
so we're about six points and you saw
those increases in uh the the report
coming from a big increase almost almost
30 increase in the year ahead outlook um
for the economy and a 17 jump in
personal financial expectations so
people getting a little bit more
optimistic about the state of the
economy that is a good thing and we
finally saw that from the university of
michigan's report
so again maybe we are maybe we're
hitting the top on inflation maybe we're
hitting the bottom on consumer sentiment
and those are both good things again
want to thank everybody who's tuned in
so far for the live stream we've been
going on about 20 minutes so i want to
thank everybody who started and who
stuck with me everyone who tuned in who
kind of caught this or caught the alert
on youtube appreciate you guys tuning in
again we'll be doing this again on
monday and hopefully going forward we'll
just be trying to you know get an
opportunity for me to just talk with you
guys direct and straight and tell you
what's going on in the markets and the
economy things you may have missed uh
from this week um so again let's let's
talk we talked about this week we got
that big we've got a bunch of big data
reports i think we have squarely seen
what inflation is doing and what it's
doing to the market it's sending stock
prices down it's sending bond prices
down and yields up
and we
there are some expectations from
analysts from economists from folks who
watch these things that we are hitting
the top on inflation potentially the
bottom on consumer sentiment those are
good things next week we get a lot of
housing data so we get the nahb national
association of home builders
housing market index that's closely
followed and that's going to tell us
what are folks doing we have seen this
trend for a number of months where
buying actual number of houses sold
drops but the prices rise does that
continue and at what level we're seeing
double digit increases on housing prices
and we're seeing single digit decreases
on housing purchases
will that continue because that reduces
the stock of houses available and it
pushes the prices up higher and it
reduces so we're kind of in a vicious
circle right now for the housing market
we'll get that nahb housing market index
next week as well as u.s housing starts
and building permits that's a little bit
look ahead how many housing starts and
building permits were issued what are
folks thinking in terms of building
because we need a lot more supply to
bring prices down especially with
mortgage rates at five percent we also
get that existing home sales report next
week that's going to be big to watch
that trend so again what do bond rates
do and as we reach this 2.8 level that
we're at now and move closer to 3
what happens on mortgage rates and how
does that affect home affordability and
overall inflation these are all things
that we are going to find out more about
next week and that we learned a lot
about this week um
again as we look back at the stock
market let's take a check in uh the dow
is incrementally negative it's down
about .03 percent still about flat on
the day the s p 500 is still about down
about
0.75 percent the nasdaq up about 1.6 or
sorry down about 1.6 nasdaq is down
about 1.6
those rising bond yields scaring
investors again
as we see um recap again just to go back
and talk about everything we've talked
about we talked about earnings season jp
morgan chase and the banks having a
rough go of it but this was expected
nothing to to get super excited about or
super distraught about if you're an
investor
the dollar hitting a two-year high or
the euro hitting a two-year low against
the dollar that's big on the ecb meeting
the european central bank meeting this
morning them saying yes we are going to
slow net asset purchases but not right
away we're not in a hurry we're going to
get it done
and you know gold down
oil down kind of a real down day to end
this early to in this short trading week
for the market next week look at housing
we'll be watching those reports uh so
want to thank you guys all again for
tuning in to this live stream i'm dion
rabowen this is my channel on youtube
appreciate everyone who tuned in whether
you started from the beginning and stuck
with me or jumped on midway through we
are going to wind this down but thank
you all so much for tuning in to the
live stream and i hope you'll be back
with us when we do this again monday and
looking forward and i look forward to
seeing you guys all